now I'd like to introduce our speaker
professor Rajan Patel PhD is a search
scientist at Google where he has led
several successful projects resulting in
the integral use of live traffic
experiments and search quality
evaluation is also a statistician on the
team that developed the Google Flu
Trends obviously been busy of recent
times as a powerfully powerful available
tool which mines Google search logs for
flu related activity and estimates
influenza-like illness rates in each of
the 50 US states he developed a model
which uses queries to predict
influenza-like illness rates a paper on
this research detecting influenza
epidemics using search engine query data
was published in 2008 in nature part of
joining Google dr. Patel worked at Angie
and incorporated as a senior bio
statistician and then as a biostatistics
manager while he was at Amgen he
conducted several statistical analyses
for early phase clinical trials and
preclinical trials dr. de Patel is
currently an adjunct professor in
biostatistics at Emory University where
he received his PhD from biostatistics
Department Wallet and rekey developed
novel statistical methods to analyze
functional connectivity of the brain
using functional magnetic resonance
imaging fMRI data he's also a visiting
instructor here in the department of
statistics at Stanford University now
I'd like to turn over the floor to dr.
Patel hello welcome to data mining the
tool of the Information Age of
revolution so to motivate today's
webinar I wanted to start with a quote
from one of Google's co-founders Sergey
Brin every year Sergey writes a letter
to shareholders in the general public
called the founders letter and in this
year's letter he explicitly mentioned
data mining
so Sergey said just a few months ago we
released Google Flu Trends a service
that uses our log data to predict flu
incidents weeks ahead of estimates by
the Centers for Disease Control it's
amazing how existing data set typically
used for improving
qualities can be brought to bear on a
seemingly unrelated issue and can help
to save lives
I believe this sort of approach can do
even more going beyond monitoring to
inferring potential causes of tears and
disease this is just one example of how
large datasets such as search logs
coupled with powerful data mining can
improve the world while safeguarding
privacy so hopefully that shows how
important data mining can be and what
what great tools can come out of a guide
of mine so what is data mining depending
upon who you ask
you'll hear many different definitions
so I'll just provide one coming from a
statistical background my definition
might be different than someone else's
but but here's the definition that's
used in the textbook that we'll be using
for the stats 202 class data mining is
the product process of automatically
discovering useful information in large
data repositories so the key one of the
key words there is automatically and
another key where there is a large data
repository and those are typically the
two the two aspects most commonly
associated with data mining so on the
bottom right-hand side of this slide I
give you the process of a typical data
mining solution typically when people
talk about data mining or teach data
mining in a class they focus on the the
aspect of it where you have your
pre-process the data and you apply
different methods such as those that
we'll talk about today are like
clustering classification regression
Association analysis bayesian methods
etc to find to build a model interpret
data and evaluate your data however in
the applied world when you're really
doing data mining the process is a lot
more involved and a lot more in-depth
you have a large data repository from
which you need to select appropriate
data pre-process that data and develop
the attributes that you'll use to
actually data mine
before you can actually apply some of
the algorithms that we commonly talked
about in data mining so if you notice
there's an arrow pointing from the
problem question question of interest to
the data repository and that arrow
points after the data repository has
been generated so why does the problem
formulation come after the data and this
is one thing that separates data mining
from from other hypothesis testing
frameworks or learning from frameworks
the data is often there before you you
formulate the question of interest this
is the difference between hypothesis
testing versus hypothesis generation and
data mining we often generate hypotheses
where as for example in clinical trials
research or or other areas you might
test hypotheses whether a drug is good
for a patient or not you would test that
hypothesis collect the data and analyze
that hypothesis so you often don't have
control over what your data looks like
and because of that the selection the
pre-processing the transformation steps
are all critical in transforming that
data to a format that's most useful for
you so before moving on I wanted to give
the example of Google Flu Trends so our
goal in the flu trends group was to
estimate flu rates in 50 US states using
Google search query patterns so Google
has this large database of search
queries issued by people just like
yourself from all over the world and we
felt that there's a powerful signal
there that could be mined and could be
it could help the general public for the
College of Public Health so the data in
our case and this is of course an
abbreviated view of the original data is
each each search query that we receive
the time span
that it came in and the location from
which it was issued so typically with
some granularity were able to determine
with a level of confidence where a
search query came from so our original
data looks something like this but
before going forward we wanted to select
out just queries that came from the US
because our initial goal was to just
look at queries or queries associated
with flu that that comes from the US and
not only that but we wanted to look at
queries that occurred a certain number
of times because what our interest was
was to find patterns of query patterns
Accords that had patterns that matched
flu like illness rates and during the
pre-processing phase we transformed our
data into a time series for each
location where a location was a US state
so that each query had a time series of
how many times it occurred over the last
five years in that state and then we
rolled that up so that each of the
counts were done had a weekly basis
because the the training data provided
by the Centers for Disease Control had
that time resolution as well so we did
all of this we actually did quite a bit
more in terms of spam removal and spike
removal News News removal as well before
even beginning the data mining process
at this point we restarted running our
data mining model which which is similar
to a linear regression model to find
queries that correlated with our I oh I
raised truth data and then finally
showed that the model actually can
estimate flu-like illness very well over
the course of an unseen season so this
is the process we used to develop Google
Flu Trends it's a fairly standard data
mining process but I wanted to
illustrate that once some of the
important steps that we took happened
well before the data mining step itself
where we we actually use these
correlative methods
identify flu related queries so before
we go further I want to discuss a little
bit what we'll talk about today first
we'll give some some more industry and
academic examples of data mining then
talk about what is and what isn't
data mining and to briefly discuss the
origins of data mining identifying types
of data mining and introduce some
methodology often used in data mining
we'll go into more detail on the
methodology in the stats 202 class this
summer but I just wanted to introduce
the methodology a little bit today
finally we'll talk about some of the
challenges remaining in that money so
what are some examples of data mining so
Safeway which is a big retail grocery
store you can use your purchase data and
so if you've noticed Safeway can provide
you these discount cards where when you
when you swipe them you often get a
discount on some of their products and
what that helps Safeway do is track what
you're purchasing and and help present
you with relevant coupons when you've
purchased certain items so they use a
data mining methodology to provide those
coupons to you and they use and and
provide those those discount cards to
users to help better serve better serve
customers
similarly Amazon uses your browse
history and your purchase history to
identify items that you might like or
items that you may want to purchase and
that's that's helps separate Amazon from
its competitors in terms of in terms of
converting the page views into purchases
State Farm
oops State Farm and which is an
insurance company as do all insurance
companies build models of your
likelihood of filing the claim and how
much that claim might be based on people
like yourself so predictive models so
that they can help better estimate what
your premiums should be furthermore an
academic example of data mining
that I was involved with a few years ago
was is to find the functionally
connected brain regions from functional
MRI data so the scope of data mining is
far and wide from neuroscience insurance
retail groceries Google searches other
searches there's quite a bit that can be
done so the term data mining is very
very broad in scope what is and what
isn't data mining so so remember the
definition again is given at the bottom
data mining is the process of
automatically discovering useful
information in large data repositories
but the process is often quite complex
so looking up a phone number in a
directory is that data mining well a
directory is a large data repository and
looking up a phone number could be
automatic if the directory had some
search functionality but but that's not
really data mining it's not we're not
just discovering useful information from
a large source we're just finding
getting returned at some of the data
that's in that repository and another
example what data mining is and is
issuing a search engine query for the
for or the query Amazon well the search
engine might be using data mining to
return those results but you're not
mining for data by just issuing the
query there's something more complex to
data mining that makes it what it is so
for example if you use information and
directory to find which names are more
prevalent in certain US locations that
would be an example of data mining so if
you were able to find that oh oh
Connally is common in Boston or Johnson
is common in Alabama or something like
that and that would be an example of
data mining furthermore grouping
together similar documents returned by a
search engine so let's say Google
returned documents relating to the
Amazon rainforest and amazon.com how
could you use the information in those
documents to group them into like
categories that process could be
considered by the money
obviously the definition of data mining
and what is and what isn't data mining
might differ depending upon what what
perspective you're coming from but but
from from the perspective we're coming
from today those are the examples we'll
use so some of the origins of data
mining data mining draws ideas from
machine learning artificial intelligence
pattern recognition statistics computer
science in general and the databases so
if you look at the Venn diagram on the
right so I'm a statistician so so for me
data mining comes comes from the
statistics from a statistics perspective
from computer scientists that comes from
a machine learning perspective so you
might learn a little bit more about
boosting and bagging and various machine
learning techniques support vector
regression etc that come from from this
side from the statistics side you learn
a little bit about logistic regression
and linear models etc on the database
side frankly I don't know too much about
but the database side contributes to the
enormity of the data and help solve the
problems with regards to scale so some
of the traditional techniques in each of
those three areas are may be unsuitable
because well in statistics when you have
too much data or it has too high
dimensionality a lot of the statistical
methods begin to break down so that's
why combining with machine learning
artificial intelligence database systems
data mining can help answer some of the
problems with the data of that size so
standard data mining tasks can be broken
down into two groups
descriptive tasks and predictive tasks
so descriptive tasks are typically
defined as when you are looking for
human interpretable patterns that
describe the data so you're not
necessarily trying to make predictions
from the die
but you're trying to understand the data
better so for example clustering if you
have a set of observations and you want
to group them into different groups but
you don't know necessarily what those
groups are in a predefined manner
clustering can help Association analysis
we'll talk about a little bit later as
well as clustering where you find
patterns in in sets of items that are in
your observations and predictive tasks
which are which may be more commonly
associated with data mining where you
use some variables in your data set to
predict unknown or future values of
these variables of other variables so
for example can you classify whether
someone is more likely to cheat on their
taxes based on the data you have about
them or regression is an example from
the flu trends regression is the type of
diamond we use for food trends where we
estimated the influenza-like illness
rate given flu or given search query
data so we'll talk a little bit about
clustering Association analysis and
classification today in SAS 202 we'll go
into all four as well as anomaly
detection and we'll go into quite a bit
of detail in the regression talk about
different regression approaches
classification we'll talk about
different classification algorithms with
clustering we'll talk about hierarchical
clustering k-means clustering how to
identify the optimal number of clusters
in your data and we'll spend a little
bit time on Association analysis as well
so we'll go into far more detail on not
only the algorithms behind each of these
data mining tasks but we'll go into
examples and learn how to actually how
to actually implement these data mining
tasks in statistical programming
language called our
all right so so let's start with
classification which was one of the
predictive type tasks for data mining so
given a collection of records or a
training set where we know the class of
a particular record can we find a model
for one of the attributes that's a
function for the other attributes that
classifies new records or classifies
that new records as accurately as
possible for that class attribute and
then typically we split our data into a
training set and the test set where
we're able to use the class attributes
of the training set to train our model
and then we see how well we're able to
predict our predict observations in the
class attributes that we want to predict
for using our test set so let's start
with an example so each record in this
data set is information about an
individual and what we'd like to be able
to predict is whether they're likely to
cheat on their taxes or not so the IRS
builds models every year and or they
build a model and try to identify who is
more likely to cheat on their taxes than
others so that they can target their
audits more effectively if they randomly
audited people chances are they they
would get a lot of false positives so
this way building a model they're able
to allocate for those their resources
more effectively so some of the
attributes they use to build their model
are well did the user or did the did the
person get a refund this year and that
would be a categorical attribute did is
the person single or married or divorced
is the what's the taxable income of the
individual and that would be a
continuous attribute so in our data set
we have two categorical attributes in
one continuous attribute and the class
attributes that we're trying to predict
is whether that individual was likely to
cheat on their taxes or not
so in our training data we actually have
truth data
whether those individuals did cheat on
their data or on their taxes or not and
we would like to build a classifier and
essentially in this case it would be a
logistic regression model to determine
whether unforeseen observations would or
unforeseen individuals would cheat on
their on their taxes or not so we split
our data into a training set and a test
set and see how well we were able to
predict whether individuals cheated or
not on the test set
so the classifier in this case from my
perspective logistic regression you can
also use support vector machines there's
quite a few different classifiers that
are out there and we'll talk more about
that and stats two or two unfortunately
we don't have time to go into specific
classifiers today another classification
example that I worked on while at Emory
is classifying whether microcosmic
microcalcifications in the breasts are
benign or malignant so in this example
the data is initially a digital
mammography image which are very high
resolution images that where each pixel
is often about 50 micrometers in size
and the image is about 2,500 by 2500
pixels and from these images it's not
difficult to identify where certain
micro calcifications are using existing
techniques but it is a little bit more
challenging to identify whether those
micro micro calcifications or belong
benign or malignant and it's critical
for the patient to identify whether
they're benign or malignant because that
could be the difference between having
to undergo surgery or not one of the
most important steps in classifying
micro calcifications is coming up with
the attributes that you'll use to
classify to build your classification
model so one particular attribute you
can use is the grayscale intensity of
the micro calcification another one is
what's the circumference to area ratio
the micro counselor
so for example the most malignant
microfabricated
Moshe calcifications often have a very
high circumference to area ratio whereas
benign microcalcifications tend to have
lower micro have lower ratios another
attribute that you might derive is a
major access to minor access Radio ratio
where the major axis is the length of
the longest point in the calcification
and the minor axis is the width of the
micro calcification and then also you
could use the pixel intensity histogram
of the micro calcification there's
there's quite a few attributes you can
use and you don't have to find the
attributes that certainly are correlated
with whether the tumor is benign or
whether a micro calcification is benign
or malignant for you the the goal is to
find as many attributes as you can and
the classifier can help determine which
ones are useful and and how useful each
one is this is an example of where a lot
of the work goes into finding the
attributes and not necessarily building
a great classifier or given attributes
so a descriptive technique for data
mining is one of the descriptive
techniques we'll talk about today is
clustering
so what's clustering so given a set of
observations each of them having a set
of attributes and a similarity score or
similarity measure among those sets of
attributes find clusters that
observations in one cluster are more
similar to another and observations and
separate clusters are less similar to
another so the goal of clustering is to
group observations that have similar of
a similar set of attributes into
different clusters and/or into into
clusters where each within each cluster
observations have similar sets of
attributes there's different similarity
measures that you can use to determine
whether how disparate a set of
attributes are Euclidean distance is one
mahalo novi distance which adjusts for
the correlation across pairs of
attributes and other other problems
specific type distance measures would
work as well in fact 202 we'll go into
more detail as to what euclidean
distance is how it's calculated how it's
used
how what mountain Mahalo know be
distance is and go into other distance
measures as well but coming up with a
distance metric to define how disparate
attributes are is an important part of
the clustering process so here's just a
visualization of clustering of three
clusters of observations where you want
to maximize the intra cluster distance
so that the sorry the inter cluster
distance or the distance between two
clusters and minimize the intra cluster
distance so the distance between
observations in the same cluster in such
- OH - we'll go over a couple different
clustering methods one of which is
k-means where you pre specify the number
of clusters in the in the data set and
k-means will will arrange the
observations in two clusters that best
minimize inter cluster distance and
maximize inter cluster distance and then
there's another family of clustering
algorithms it's called hierarchical
clustering and we'll talk about
agglomerative hierarchical clustering in
the class where you don't pre specify
the number of clusters but they're
clustering occurs in something called a
dendrogram
and eventually you cut off the
dendrogram at the number of clusters
that is most appropriate and we'll talk
about how to do that in the class so
another another clustering example is in
the in Google Flu Trends we wanted to be
able to cluster search queries that have
similar volume patterns so we wanted to
be able to understand well which queries
have similar user in times which
korie's go have increase in volume at
the same time and decrease in volume at
the same time so on this plot I'm
showing the the normalized search volume
for the query flu symptoms as well as
the normalized search volumes for the
great influenza and you can actually
make plots like this yourself if you go
to Google Trends which I believe is at
google.com slash Trends you can actually
then download this data in CSV format
and do your own data mining with queries
of interest as well
but the idea behind clustering similar
search queries is well if can I find the
queries a set of queries that might be
news related or can I find a set of
queries that have some specific pattern
that I can I can attribute to to some
other effect and either use those
queries in my in my flu model or if omit
those queries from my food model and so
we did use quite a bit of clustering in
Google Flu Trends and in this when
clustering flu queries the attributes
are the query counts or the normalized
score accounts at each time point so you
have quite a few attributes and they're
highly correlated with each other so you
would want to adjust for the correlation
across time point but the attributes so
we actually had weekly data going back
four or five years so we had two or
three hundred attributes in our data and
that's when the scale of the data begins
to grow beyond what there's typically
typically used in statistics
so finally Association rule discovery is
another descriptive task where given a
set of records each containing some
number of items from a collection can
you produce dependency rules which will
predict the occurrence of an item based
on the currencies of other items so the
Association rule discovery is important
for so for example amazon.com or so
let's save this example a Safeway a
grocery store where user one purchases a
subset of all the items
for sale at Safeway he purchases bread
coke and milk and user 2 or a shopper
number 2 purchases beer and bread
shopper 3 purchases beer coke diaper
diapers and milk and shopper for
purchases a set items shopper 5
purchases a set of items and what we'd
want to be able to do is discover
relationships between the items when
somebody purchases milk are they more
likely to purchase purchase coke when
somebody purchases diaper and milk
together are they more likely to
purchase beer so let's let's go into an
example from from from Safeway so let's
let's see if we so let the rule to
discover it be like bagels - potato
chips so bagels is in the antecedent and
potato chips is in the consequent
so having potato chips in the consequent
allows us to be able to determine what
can be done to boost its sales so potato
chips in the consequent we see that
bagels is in the antecedent if we sell
more bagels then we can sell more potato
chips with bagels in the antecedent we
can be we can use that to see which
products would be affected if this store
discontinued selling bagels so if
Safeway note no longer sold bagels then
the sales of potato chips would be
effective as affected and finally if you
had bagels in the antecedent and potato
chips in the consequent you can see what
other products should be sold with
bagels to promote the sale of potato
chips so for example if coke and bagels
were in the antecedent then both of
those would be would affect the the
sales of potato chips
so this is how Association analysis and
Association rules are often used at at
retailers so not only safe way of course
but Amazon and then almost every
retailer in the world and it helps
identify which other items might be my
we might be a shopper want to buy or to
present items to them as in the form of
coupons or you know in Amazon's case as
you know items you might you may like
they use an association analysis to do
that so finally so some of the
challenges remaining in data mining so
data the data is often very complex and
very noisy as you remember from the
beginning of the talk the data is often
often existed before is you are you
developed a problem or question of
interest so you aren't able to collect
the data yourself in the format you want
and and have complete control of the
data and converting this complex and
noisy data into something that's useful
and usable to you in terms of what
attributes that it has and and and so
forth is a very important process in
data mining and it's one of oftentimes
the most difficult and overlooked steps
the same goes with data quality the
privacy preservation is often is
recently become very important for
example with the launch of Google Flu
Trends we're using individual search
query data so search grades that
individuals issue and you have to be
very conscientious about the privacy of
those users so we went to great lengths
to anonymize the data and make and
aggregate the data to make sure that no
one individual could be identified from
from any of the data that we use lately
streaming that has become more and more
important there's a microblogging
service called Twitter which is exploded
in 2009 and streaming data in the form
of micro blogs and and Twitter searches
are becoming more and more the I guess
more and more prevalent and Twitter is
going to Twitter and other similar
services are going to use data mining
quite a bit to identify what hot topics
are hot trends are what useful webpages
are etc to better serve their users
and in an issue that Twitter will have
to deal with as this Google and other
and other companies is scalability of
their services so it's important for
data mining especially with the size of
the data sets and the increasing size of
the data sets that scalability of the
algorithms and of the the platforms with
which you implement those algorithms can
grow to meet your needs and then finally
from a statistic that efficient
perspective the dimensionality of the
data often causes the greatest concerns
with the methodology so developing
methodology that scales with the
dimensionality of the data is critically
important so I want to thank thank you
for attending the class today I believe
Paul will follow it will follow up with
some some comments and then I'll begin
to answer some of the questions that
have been queued up over the next five
to ten minutes thanks dr. Patel thank
you very much and now what I'd like to
do is go over some background on the
Stanford center for professional
development and how you can actually
enroll in dr. patel's course data mining
and analysis first of the Stanford
center for professional development is
in delivering education to industry as
the bridge between Stanford and industry
for over 40 years now we deliver a
number of graduate courses certificates
and programs about which I will speak in
a few moments and also professional
education our goal in doing this is not
only to extend the Graduate Stanford
level content to maintain the vitality
of the Silicon Valley but also to allow
you as individuals to stay on top of
your game we have a number of different
offerings and I'd like to walk through
those our Center offers about 230
graduate courses every year those can be
taken in a variety of different options
that you see here the first is the non
degree option where students without
submitting transcripts as I sorry
without submitting GREs and actually
applying to the Department
simply submit a transcript to SCPD and
gain access and take those courses for
graduate credit at Stanford University
students who pursue this can actually
accumulate up to 18 units which may be
transferred in to variety of different
graduate master's degrees that we offer
at Stanford students can also bundle
those courses the SCPD has worked with
various departments including statistics
to create graduate certificates data
mining and analysis for instance is part
of the certificate in data mining and
applications offered by the Department
of Statistics these graduate
certificates are focused in a specific
area such as the one I just mentioned
and comprise typically of three to five
graduate courses this allows the
individual who may already even have a
PhD to get some additional education in
a domain we know one thing is certain
that education and these various areas
continue to evolve and this is a great
way to demonstrate how you can remain
up-to-date to your teammates as well as
to your boss and others in your group
finally we offer two different to a
master's degree which is called the
honors cooperative program if you're
interested in this candidates must apply
like any other graduate students to the
department of interests and the SCPD
allows this candidates that once
accepted to participate on a part-time
basis students can take up to five years
to complete that degree and as I
mentioned if you had participated in the
non degree option up to eighteen units
can transfer into that master's degree
we also offer an audit program where
students who want to just observe the
content can participate and there is no
credit associated with that the Stanford
center for professional development is
one of the leaders in distance education
since 1999 we've been offering master's
degrees in engineer
and other disciplines at a distance we
do this by creating lectures which are
an offered in nine television classrooms
here on Stanford's campus we capture
those and extend those on a streaming
basis those typically are offered about
an hour after the class has occurred
students engage with faculty via email
and also if the class has homeworks and
assignments those are completed
typically online and through the
Stanford center for professional
developments distribution unit finally
if there is a test required that we do
require that companies identify an exam
monitor who may not be your spouse or
best friend to provide some secure way
of making sure that the exam is taken by
the student and the time allotted once
you have been able to identify the the
course of interest as say the course
that we've shared with you today I'm
going to walk through some of the ways
you'll need to engage with us for a
course enrollment the summer quarter is
now open and will remain open until June
17 students can enroll in a variety of
different ways the most common of which
is the non degree option category if you
are as you can see here if you belong to
a member company as identified on scpd's
website you have a slightly better per
unit cost than if you do not so would
encourage you to look at that if you're
interested in auditing again the member
company has some slight advantage the
nice thing here is that this allows you
to participate and observe the course
just as you might have when you were
once on the University campus not
engaged with the faculty member or the
class per se but get a chance to
experience and deserve the content once
you have decided you would like to
participate we actually have in
scpd's new website something called the
my Stanford connection we encourage you
whether or not you are actually actually
interested in pursuing a graduate course
to enroll there we often extend free
seminars webinars and archived webinars
such as the one you've experienced today
and my Stanford connection will allow
you access to those it will also allow
you the ability to register for courses
graduate courses through a CD what you
do is you go to our website once you're
logged in and have your user ID you can
I do a quick search for instance on
stats 202 and you can simply click
enroll in this section and you'll see
the various options this will drive you
once completed we encourage you to click
on the carts very much like an
amazon.com experience where you can
click on that cart to make sure you have
the right items and proceed to checkout
your page will look very much like this
or you can identify the correct category
based on member company or you're taking
this for non degree option credit an
audit option and so on and then you can
proceed to checkout to the tuition
payment screen I've given you some sense
of the SBPD and how we operate what I'm
interested in knowing from you right now
is how much how many of you are are
interested in taking data mining and
analysis stats tool to be helpful to
know that I see some people registering
or voting right now I'm going to give
you a few more seconds to click in
before I close the polls again the the
categories are I'm interested in taking
this course this summer make sure you
didn't take in the course next time that
is offered I have some questions please
contact me or no I'm not interested at
this time
okay the selections are still coming in
I'm going to close the polls now you can
see that eight of you are interested in
taking this this summer
seems like eleven are interest
and also eleven are not interested we
certainly can create these webinars to
give you a glimpse into the state of the
art and we also hope that this may drive
some interest to the courses that SAPD
offers I did want to highlight two
upcoming webinars on May 14 we have a
program with my colleague Belinda quo
which will give you some perspective not
only on the graduate programs about what
you heard today but also the
professional education offerings where
we address content for engineers
technology managers professionals and
executives so we have a full complement
of offerings that's tomorrow May 14 at
11:30 and then in two weeks we have a
webinar featuring Professor Simon Wong
and Stephen Boyd who will be talking
about future opportunities of Electrical
Engineering
Yee matters that's at 10 a.m. Pacific
daylight we hope that you might you or
your colleagues and I join us for one or
more of these webinars to learn more
about our offerings finally we encourage
you to enroll in dr. patel's course this
link will be provided here for a few
moments we do appreciate your taking the
time here today we do have a number of
questions coming in and we would like to
actually try that to answer those I'm
going to actually turn the floor over to
dr. Patel who might be able to answer a
couple of these questions live we have a
few more minutes and if you do have
questions for dr. Patel please send them
in now we have an active Q&A session so
the first question that we received was
with regard to the data to data
filtering is your data skewed or swamped
once an event like the current swine flu
occurs and numerous us reviewers conduct
related queries through Google so this
question is about the Google Flu Trends
product and weather issues I guess news
related events such as the current swine
flu affect the data in the model so part
of the model
before we actually use the model we
filter our query stream for news related
events and we have a separate machine
learning pipeline that identifies
queries that may have been likely issued
due to due to due to a news related
event and we filter those queries out so
oftentimes you know most of the time
this works pretty well sometimes we let
some things slip through but it's a very
important goal of ours for the system to
work not only when there isn't a
particularly unusual and news related
event going on but even during during
something like this swine flu that we've
seen over the last month or so the
second question is for steps 202 is a
prior background in our or other general
programming language recommended for the
course so experience with programming
languages is recommended
however experience with our in
particular or any particular programming
language isn't isn't necessary and if
you don't know our if you haven't used
our before don't worry about it but
hopefully you've used some some
statistical tool before maybe it maybe
it's R or MATLAB or SAS even Excel
more advanced Excel or other programming
languages so that because we'll dive
into R but I will provide a background
within to R as well as Excel but
hopefully you can get off the ground
running in terms of how programming
languages typically work okay
the textbook first that's two or two
will be the same textbook that was used
last year it's called introduction to
data mining by Tenma Steinbach and Kumar
so again its introduction to data mining
by ten Steinbach and Kumar if you if you
go to Amazon or Google and type in
introduction to data mining time ten
Steinbeck and Kumar you'll find the book
listed there the next question is what
pre-class reading can a student conduct
prior to enrolling in the stats 202
class so I think in order to prepare for
the class and to get yourself up to
speed as much as you can get familiar
with our as a statistical tool that
would be optimal because then you'll be
able to focus on the data mining
methodologies themselves and not
necessarily have to worry about having
to learn programming language while
trying to learn new statistical methods
and data mining methods other than that
I don't think there's there's too much
that you'll have to read and if you're
interested in getting a broader
background on clustering classification
and Association analysis for aggression
etc I would just say that you know start
searching on the web maybe Wikipedia and
reading a little bit about what's out
there might help what are the
differences between sets 202 252 and 315
B Paul can you answer that one
well I we have a variety of different
courses in in stats and what I would
encourage you to do is go to ETSU pd's
website and do a compare and contrast
against those topics I can tell you that
that's 252 is quite a popular course and
features a number of guest lectures
talking about how they implement and use
statistical methods in their own
business we are offering 252 in the
spring but with the others I would have
to
refer to the various descriptions on a
securities website which are reasonably
robust I would also encourage students
if you have questions we can direct them
to our course advisor for statistics who
is quite good and will be quite quick on
the uptake regarding any questions or
issues Ashish is a PhD candidate within
statistics and is reasonably responsive
within the 24 hour business day so if
you have further questions I would
direct you there the one of the next
questions are actually the two next
questions has to do with the level of
math background or staff background
required for stats 202 will there be a
review of key concepts so the FAFSA 2 is
an introduction introductory course so
we will go over basics like you know how
to make a histogram how to visualize
your data well it will really take it
from the top so I think that the level
of math background will be will be quite
quite minimal I wouldn't worry too much
about not having used advanced math
concepts in the past however concepts
like probability and perhaps even
conditional probability might be
worthwhile to review but beforehand
especially as they come up in terms of
in association analysis and and in
logistic regression etc as an SP CD
student can I come to the classroom for
stats - OH - generally speaking it is up
to the faculty member in the space in
the room what we do ask you to do is
submit your question to the SCPD
customer service link which is on our
website and then we'll get that to dr.
Patel often the rooms are quite small in
the summer and so we are just generally
not sure about the room allocation of an
availability
it is indeed up to the professor
generally speaking students in the
non-degree option CAD
Gouri are encouraged to take courses at
a distance we have quite a robust
enrollment in that category and if every
student showed up at one time we have a
real problem with capacity for those
students who are on Stanford's campus
the master's degrees candidates are
typically allowed to come to Stanford's
campus if they're local and again if if
the classroom allows with that what I'd
like to do is thank you for your
attendance and your questions today's
presentation will be recorded and we'll
be sending out the link to all of the
attendees including those who are unable
to show up we encourage you to extend
those links to colleagues who may have
missed a session we do also welcome in
choirs and follow up there were many
good questions we'll be taking some of
the questions offline and we thank you
for your attendance today on today's
webinar we look forward to seeing you in
future
SCPD webinars and we wish you a very
good day thank you very much